BURGER KING CHICKEN FRIES.
SURE ENOUGH, THEY WERE
DISCONTINUED FOR 2012.
LIKE MY LIFE
DOESN'T SUCK ENOUGH.
DO YOU STILL FREQUENT
A BURGER KING?
UH, NO, I'VE BEEN BOYCOTTING
THEM EVER SINCE.
I'M TALKING ABOUT,
SHE WAS HUGE.
A BIG, BIG LADY.
YOU--YOU CAN'T BELIEVE IT,
HOW HUGE SHE WAS.
MY FAVORITE FOOD
IS BEANS AND CORNBREAD.
I LOVE BEANS
AND CORNBREAD.
'CAUSE I'M JUST
A COUNTRY BOY.
YOU KNOW, LOVE
THAT BEANS AND CORNBREAD.
'CAUSE THERE AIN'T NOTHING WRONG
WITH BEANS AND CORNBREAD.
I HAVE BEEN A REPUBLICAN
IN TIMES GOOD,
AND I HAVE BEEN A REPUBLICAN
IN TIMES BAD!
DANIEL TOSH IS GONNA BE
MY PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN MANAGER.
WHOO!
HELL, YEAH!
I HAVE NEVER BEEN NOSTALGIC
BECAUSE UNLIKE EVERYONE ELSE,
I DON'T GET UGLIER AND FATTER
AS I GET OLDER.
THOSE THREE FOLKS
I KIND OF REMEMBER
ARE THE FEW, THE PROUD,
THE REDEEMED.
I'VE BEEN REDEEMING PEOPLE
PROFESSIONALLY
FOR SEVEN YEARS NOW.
15 ALL TOLD.
EVERY PERSON I REDEEM IS LIKE
FAMILY TO ME,
WHICH IS WHY I AVOID THEM
AS LONG AS POSSIBLE.
BUT ONCE IN A WHILE,
IT'S IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE
OUR BELOVED TOSH LEGENDS
DIDN'T DIE ALONE
IN THEIR APARTMENTS
WITH CATS EATING THEIR FACES.
THAT'S WHY I FLEW PHIL, DARRELL,
AND THAT CHICKEN FRIES GUY
BACK TO HOLLYWOOD
FOR THE THIRD ANNUAL
TOSH.OH, THAT'S WHAT
THEY'RE UP TO NOW
REDEMPTION REUNION SPECTACULAR.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
WELCOME TO TALKING TOSH,
THE ONLY SHOW THAT COMES ON
DURING TOSH WHERE WE TALK ABOUT
WHAT TOSH IS TALKING
ABOUT ON TOSH.
I AM YOUR HOST, DANIEL TOSH,
FROM TOSH.0.
LET'S TALK TOSH.
I'LL ALWAYS REMEMBER
OUR FIRST GUEST
FOR BEING PASSIONATE,
ENTHUSIASTIC, AND WAY TOO LOUD.
PLEASE WELCOME PHIL DAVISON!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
HOW YOU DOING, DANIEL?
- PHIL, GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN.
- GOOD TO SEE YOU TOO.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
ALL RIGHT, FIRST THING'S FIRST,
SCREAM AS LOUD AS YOU CAN.
AHH!
WHAT HAVE YOU
BEEN UP TO, PHIL?
JUST BEEN WORKING.
WORK IN OHIO
AS A LEGAL ASSISTANT.
YOU DIDN'T BECOME
STARK COUNTY'S TREASURER.
THAT'S CORRECT.
HAS ANY COLLEGE ASKED YOU
TO GIVE THE COMMENCEMENT SPEECH?
NO, THEY HAVEN'T.
THAT'S A SHAME.
I'M PISSED ABOUT IT, MAN.
HAVE YOU EVER SENT ANY PHOTOS
OF YOUR PENIS TO ANYONE?
YES, I HAVE.
PHIL, YOU CAN'T
BE DOING THAT.
YOU DATING ANYONE?
- YES.
- NICE.
YEAH, SHE'S NOT HAPPY
WITH ME.
WELL, WHY WOULD SHE BE?
EXACTLY, YOU KNOW.
HOW MUCH DO YOU SPEND
ON DRUGS A MONTH?
ABOUT $200.
IT'S ABOUT 1/4 BAG A WEEK.
SUM UP OBAMA'S PRESIDENCY
IN ONE WORD.
FAILURE.
DID YOU INVEST YOUR MONEY
FROM THE SHOW WISELY?
YES, I HAVE.
I'VE PUT IT IN AN IRA FUND,
AND OVER THE LAST FOUR YEARS,
IT'S GROWN EXPONENTIALLY.
SO I'M DOING FINE.
IS THERE ANYTHING
YOU'D LIKE TO SAY
TO THE HATERS OUT THERE?
YOU KNOW WHAT
I'D LIKE TO TELL 'EM?
- WHAT'S THAT?
- [BLEEP] ALL OF YA.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
WHAT THE HELL ARE
YOU PEOPLE DOING?
YOU WANT RATINGS?
I'LL GIVE YOU RATINGS.
WELL, THAT'S ALL THE TIME
WE HAVE FOR PHIL.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
I KNOW YOU NEED TO GET BACK
TO YOUR VAN DOWN BY THE RIVER.
ALL RIGHT,
LET'S TALK MORE TOSH.
NOW, ACCORDING
TO MY CALCULATIONS,
OUR NEXT GUEST
IS MOMENTS AWAY
FROM DYING
OF KIDNEY FAILURE
BECAUSE HE ONLY
EATS FAST FOOD.
PLEASE WELCOME BACK DAVE,
THE BK-CHICKEN-FRIES GUY.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
- DAVE.
- HEY.
HAVE A SEAT.
NICE TO SEE YOU.
- YOU STILL DATING THAT REDHEAD?
- YES.
OH.
HOW SHOCKED WERE YOU
WHEN YOU FOUND OUT
BK HAD CAVED
TO OUR DEMANDS
AND BROUGHT BACK
THE CHICKEN FRY?
[CHANTING]
BRING THEM BACK.
I WAS ACTUALLY
VERY SHOCKED,
'CAUSE I JUST THOUGHT I WAS
THE ONLY ONE WHO CARED.
DAVE, I CANNOT BELIEVE
YOU ARE NOT
ON YOUR KNEES RIGHT NOW
SLOBBING ON MY KNOB.
YOU KNOW,
I MAY BE THE LENIN
OF THE CHICKEN FRIES MOVEMENT.
YOU ARE THE TROTSKY.
DID THE CHICKEN FRIES TASTE
AS GOOD AS YOU REMEMBERED?
THEY WERE STILL SPICY.
I THINK THEY WERE
A BIT SOGGIER
BECAUSE THEY CHANGED THE METHOD
IN WHICH THEY MAKE THEM,
BUT ASIDE FROM THAT,
THEY WERE PRETTY DAMN GOOD.
HOW'S YOUR HEALTH?
I'M STILL ALIVE.
I'M PROBABLY HEALTHIER
BECAUSE I'VE BECOME
SLIGHTLY LESS
OF A PICKY EATER
SINCE THE SHOW.
WHAT DO YOU ENJOY NOW
THAT YOU DIDN'T HAVE
A TASTE FOR BEFORE?
ON THE HEALTHY SIDE, RICE.
ON THE EXTREMELY
UNHEALTHY SIDE, BACON.
TALK ABOUT RICE.
ALL RIGHT, WHAT I LIKE
ABOUT RICE IS THAT
I CAN ADD AS MUCH [BLEEP]
SPICE TO IT AS POSSIBLE
AND IT JUST TASTES
LIKE THE SPICE.
DID YOU INVEST YOUR MONEY
FROM THE SHOW WISELY?
NO, IT PROBABLY JUST SAT
IN MY BANK ACCOUNT
UNTIL I PAID RENT.
DID WE COVER
AN ENTIRE MONTH'S RENT?
YES.
THAT IS INCREDIBLE.
DID YOU EVER
IN A MILLION YEARS THINK
YOU DESERVED
TO BE ON TOSH.0 TWICE?
NO.
IT'S LITERALLY
THE LEAST I COULD DO.
WHO'S READY TO TALK
MORE TOSH?
TOSH IS.
OUR NEXT GUEST WAS PLAYING
A LITTLE HARD TO GET,
BUT WE FINALLY CONVINCED HER
TO COME BACK ON THE SHOW.
PLEASE WELCOME
THE SURPRISINGLY STRONG FANNY.
[CAMERA SHUTTER CLICKING]
ALL RIGHT, I'LL TAKE
THE TAPE OFF,
BUT YOU HAVE TO PROMISE
NOT TO SCREAM.
OKAY?
ALL RIGHT.
- HELP ME! HELP--
- OKAY, OKAY.
IT LOOKS LIKE SOMEBODY HAS TO GO
BACKSTAGE AND CALM DOWN FIRST.
OH, YOUR HAIR SMELLS SO GOOD.
WHAT IS THAT?
WHAT IS THAT, A CLEMENTINE MIX,
OR TANGERINE?
I'M SO BAD AT THIS GAME.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.
OUR FINAL GUEST SAID
"BEANS AND CORNBREAD"
SIX TIMES IN A ROW,
AND EVERYONE THOUGHT
IT WAS HILARIOUS.
PLEASE WELCOME BACK STANDUP
COMEDIAN DARRELL BLUETT.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
DARRELL, DO YOU KNOW
WHERE YOU ARE RIGHT NOW?
YEAH, TALKING TO YOU.
YOU LOOK AMAZING.
WHAT'S YOUR SECRET?
JUST EATING BEANS
AND CORNBREAD.
- THAT'S IT?
- YEAH.
DO YOU EVER GET SICK AND TIRED
OF SAYING "BEANS AND CORNBREAD"?
NO, I THINK IT'S GREAT,
'CAUSE I LIKE THE ATTENTION.
HOW ARE THINGS GOING
IN DARRELL BLUETT'S WORLD?
OH, IT'S GOING GREAT.
EVERYBODY KNOW ME
BY "BEANS AND CORNBREAD."
EVEN THE POLICE EVEN
IN MY HOMETOWN,
THEY SAY, "HOW YOU DOING,
BEANS AND CORNBREAD?"
THE POLICE ARE NICE
TO YOU, THOUGH?
OH, THEY REAL NICE TO ME.
OKAY, GOOD.
WHAT DID YOU THINK OF
LOUIS C.K.'S LAST SPECIAL?
I DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHO LOUIS K IS.
HE'S NEW.
DO YOU EVER WATCH YOURSELF
ON TV?
I'VE SEEN MYSELF ONE TIME
AND I SAID,
"WHO'S THAT UGLY GUY?"
- YOU TALKING ABOUT ME?
- ME.
OH.
[LAUGHS]
I THOUGHT YOU WERE--
I THOUGHT YOU WERE
CALLING ME UGLY.
DARRELL, DO PEOPLE
ASK YOU IF I'M GAY?
YES, THEY DO.
YOU TELL 'EM I GOT
A GIRLFRIEND, RIGHT?
I TOLD 'EM, I SAID YOU GOT
PLENTY OF GIRLFRIENDS.
THANK YOU.
THEY EVEN ASK ME
IF I'M GAY SOMETIMES.
OKAY.
WHAT?
THAT'S--ARE YOU?
I DON'T THINK I AM.
I DON'T THINK SO.
YOU GOT A GIRLFRIEND
RIGHT NOW?
I DON'T HAVE A GIRLFRIEND,
BUT I'M NOT GAY.
YOU DON'T HAVE
TO GET UPSET WITH ME.
HOW MANY GOOD MINUTES OF
STANDUP DO YOU HAVE RIGHT NOW?
I CAN DO ABOUT 30 MINUTES.
WHAT'S THE RESPONSE BEEN?
THEY'VE BEEN LIKING IT.
THEY SAID I NEED TO WORK
A LOT HARDER AND STUFF
AND COME UP WITH MORE
MATERIAL AND STUFF.
I FEEL LIKE IF
I GOT MY OWN IDEAS
AND I DO WHAT I SHOULD DO,
THEN I FEEL LIKE
IT'LL BE MY MATERIAL
INSTEAD OF BEING
SOMEBODY ELSE,
'CAUSE IT'S A LOT OF PEOPLE
WANT TO TRY TO BE
LIKE SOMEBODY ELSE,
LIKE EDDIE MURPHY
OR RICHARD PRYOR
OR SOMEBODY LIKE THAT,
AND I'M NOT TRYING
TO BE LIKE THEM.
YOU KNOW, I'M JUST TRYING
TO BE MYSELF.
THE MATERIAL I GOT,
I EXPERIENCED IT FOR MYSELF,
YOU KNOW, AND THEN
I SEE THINGS MYSELF
AND I JUST USE THAT
AS WHAT I SEE, YOU KNOW,
NOT SOMEBODY ELSE
HAVE ALREADY SEEN
AND TRYING TO WORK ON
THEY MATERIAL, YOU KNOW--
THIS IS THE LONGEST
SENTENCE IN THE WORLD.
WHAT DID THEY MEXICANS SAY
WHEN TWO HOUSES FELL ON 'EM?
THEY SAID, "OH!"
GET OFF ME, HOMES.
GET OFF ME--
THAT'S A GOOD ONE.
HOW ABOUT WHEN THE GUY
WALKED IN THE ELEVATOR
AND HE ASKED THE LADY,
"HEY, CAN I SMELL YOUR FEET?"
AND SHE SAID, "NO."
AND HE GOES, "OH, IT MUST
BE YOUR PUSSY THEN."
OH.
- I AIN'T HEARD THAT ONE.
- [TITTERS]
- KNOCK, KNOCK.
- WHO'S THERE?
- ORANGE.
- ORANGE WHO?
ORANGE YOU GLAD
WE HAD YOU BACK?
DARRELL BLUETT,
EVERYBODY.
WELL, THAT'S ALL
THE TIME WE HAVE
FOR TONIGHT'S INSTALLMENT
OF TT ON THE CC.
SO ON BEHALF OF DARRELL, FANNY,
DAVE, PHIL, AND FANNY,
GOOD NIGHT, AND REMEMBER,
IF TOSH IS TALKING ABOUT IT,
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IT
ON TALKIN' TOSH.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
WAVE, DARRELL.
LISTENING
TO DARRELL BLUETT SPEAK
IS ONE OF MY FEW TRUE JOYS
IN LIFE.